la jueza eileen canon aprobó el
nombramiento de un maestro especial para
revisar los documentos recuperados por
el fbi en mara lago y también prohibió
temporalmente que el departamento de
justicia use este material para
cualquier investigación contra the onion
hasta que precisamente el maestro
especial revise los 11.000 documentos
recuperados la orden de la jueza
nombrada por tramitar y al menos por
ahora que los fiscales federales usen
pruebas clave mientras continúan
investigando si el presidente es el ex
presidente de trump retuvo ilegalmente
documentos de seguridad nacional o se
obstruyó los repetidos esfuerzos del
gobierno para que éste devolviera estos
documentos confidenciales el
departamento de justicia había advertido
ya que apelaría la decisión ante la
corte de apelaciones del circuito 11 lo
que pasa es que en esta corte nombró 6
de los 11 jueces activos ahora entonces
los abogados de trump y el departamento
de justicia tienen hasta el próximo
viernes para presentar una lista de
candidatos y empezar así este proceso
que sería largo
de hecho demorará sin duda la
investigación aunque ya él y haya
revisado todos los documentos
encontrados